well it's kind of close it's getting
closer
it's getting closer Anything Can Happen
10 vote difference
wow
I think Super solid like barely overtook
the lead in the final seconds but then
at the very end
it was a difference of
11 votes
okay
super aggressive it is
let's join the tournament
so what what's what is going to be my
super aggressive opening repertoire
I think of all the gambits
I mean maybe Safford Gambit
I'm tempted to play Budapest
I'll try a Budapest if C4 E5
I usually reserve the Budapest for
Blitz or bullet
but I did actually go through a phase of
playing this opening in classical over
the board chess
back when I was around maybe 2100
wait I was supposed to play Bishop C5
all right let's play uh let's play into
this line
Knight D2 expected
to get ready to take the pawn
which Knight to take with
oh my Bishop
oh no
I wasn't expecting A3
uh someone call an ambulance
stole my Bishop again
yeah if white takes the bishop it's
Checkmate but my opponent wasn't uh
wasn't taking the poison
this is one of the very first Budapest
traps that I learned
is basically what inspired me to play
The Budapest
the potential for the middle game
smother mates
so I think I have to take and then D6
and okay we'll have a position
[Music]
the night is nicely centralized on E5
discourages Bishop D3
and okay I'm gonna castle and then
that's a question what to do with this
bishop
because about five or maybe put the
bishop on the long diagonal
oh wow it's halfway to diplodacas
I thought you subbed like a few days ago
but now you're subbing for six months in
advance
really appreciate it
wait the pieces sound different
maybe it's it was louder
sorry if it was like loud
um
and just adjusted things
play this
okay so Bishop F5
or Bishop D7
or Bishop E6
or A5 there's a few candidate moves
that come to mind
I'm trying to visualize what White's
plan is as well
hmm
I'm really not sure here
like B6
B6 Bishop B7 actually looks very solid
I'm thinking the bishop is happiest on
this diagonal
the only concern if I play B6 there's
takes
they Pawn takes him in this
but then just Rook B8
should be okay
and because I only have one Bishop
in this case a light squared Bishop
and I want pawns on opposite color of
that Bishop so it makes sense to have
all the Pawns
on dark squares
I'll come back to for right Hood
happy half a year so white does trade
yeah I'll take
I'll take with Pawn
and control a bit more space
so Rook d8 could be a nice Tempo move
attack the queen
and
okay now I can't play Rook T8 and if I
play Bishop B7 there's Queen D7
but then Queen G5
this may be interesting
G3
Rook C8
It's actually an interesting line so
Bishop B7
Queen D7 would be the most
um
maybe one of the most critical moves
and then either Queen G5 or rookie 8 I
think are both solid
yeah let's start with Bishop B7
and down a little bit of time
but
I think when white took on E5 it kind of
conceded
any advantage that white could have
and I think this line like the line that
we went into should be a little bit
better for white because black does give
away the bishop pair
um but now it's uh I mean it's still a
strategic battle we both have light
squared Bishops
so white also wants the pawns on dark
squares
and yeah this is a decision moment
because Queen G5 G3
Rook C8
really looks okay
and it feels a little bit bad that I'm
not controlling the only
open file
that's the only file with no pawns on it
White's dominating the file for the time
being
ah Queen G4
I did not anticipate that move
I think I'll like I think I have to take
retreating is just kind of losing time
and at least in this line I can fight
for the D file
um there's a question do I which Rook do
I want to move
I'll be this Rook
the Frieza came to come in
I tried to be super aggressive this game
but we actually have a super solid
position
s let's go let's go
so for those maybe joining late at the
beginning of the stream before I played
the first game
I ran a poll
of what people
want to see me do in the opening
whether to play Super aggressive super
solid or just lots of variety
and super aggressive won the poll
all right let's take
and then bring the rook in
I wonder if White's gonna play this move
there's a funny line Rook D1 Bishop C8
Bishop G4
and I'm not actually winning a piece
but it feels like momentum is on my side
like I'm making a threat
your Rook D1 is pretty risky this bishop
A4 as well in some lines
okay
yeah so now it's it's a matter of
finding
the right approach like could attack the
pawn right away
like Bishop A6
I'm back to Amber Eric I just watched
your Instagram short of your eight
seconds checkmate with the awesome music
very cool video oh thank you you're
doing well and practical
I'm trying to figure out the aquatics
here
King f8 Bishop G4
takes takes King E7 B4
[Music]
I mean my king gets in faster but I
don't know if it matters ready papers
which combine chess engines with
language models so that they don't
hallucinate nonsense lines like chat did
recently are you looking forward to that
or not
I like how I pronounce Chachi PT
yes some some versions of AI still have
to learn how to pronounce Chachi PT
okay so let's take we're entering uh a
bishop ending
I really want to play this move
this is E4 King F1 I have but Bishop D3
there's Bishop E2 let's start with this
and this is a move I play in like every
variation
the dream is to get the king to C5 and
play A5 and start targeting the pawn
the problem is before
is likely coming
[Music]
in this Pawn do I need to defend it
probably not right away
but maybe eventually
I think I just play H6
I gotta start moving quicker
a very strategic ending
F3 does block my scope against G2
but it puts another Pawn on the light
Square
okay
play this
first step of my dream
now A5
ensuring there's no B4 check to chase me
back
but I really do much
because yeah B3
to find a new home for this bishop
I don't think Bishop A6 does anything
[Music]
like this
the coupon Garden appreciate the bits
I'm calculating
um King D2 B5
maybe I'm just in time to
make a little bit of progress
because if the king were already on C3
white would have B4 check and then C5
but now there's no way to get the pawns
so the dark squares
and if King C3
I think I played B4 here
if I take there's Bishop takes I don't
want to trade Bishops
I'm considering playing
five
interesting F5
do it
there's even a line where I suck upon
okay the goal is to play F4
if white plays F4 I take take and then
King D4 and even though I have a pawn
fixed
on the light Square my king gets very
active
I can always play G6 to defend and then
reposition the bishop
I'm down over a minute
so like to win this game I basically
have to win on the board rather than the
clock
it's XI Sparks
happy 59 months good to see you
all right let's play this first
concern as things get included down
but
trying to make the right positional
decisions
the dream is to eventually get the king
in
now it is a question like what what do I
do if I wait
maybe like I bring my king this way and
eventually either offer the bishop trade
or
say like H5 G4 is probably the
Breakthrough
um
okay there's a really funny trap here
which might not happen
if this I play this running mate
maybe I do try and pressure the clock
like I'm I'm moving around just trying
to formulate
the Breakthrough plan
I think the King has more purpose on the
king side
uh maybe I have some E4 move at some
point like Bishop D6 E4
right moment temporary Pawn sack
H5
okay so now G4 take take
it's time for G4
I mean I could have moved around a lot
more but
this does seem to make a bit of progress
because now the King has an entry point
it takes takes
we get a situation where my Pawn on F4
will be defended by the king and then
the G Pawn should fall
still probably a draw with precise play
but the position seems a little bit
shaky for white
I can take here as well
take take before
[Music]
start by taking here
oh
this
okay this gives me some hope now the
epon's a weakness as well
leave tension Bishop g4's idea
yeah sometimes these end games seem
drawn but
it can be easy to go wrong for the side
defending
now it should be a pretty
straightforward win
um because yeah the E4 Pawn can't be
defended
thing is tied down to the bishop
thank you sigoba subbing for three
months in advance
the pawn can start marching
okay
that was an instructive game
it started with uh I mean an attempted
super aggressive opening
I was trying to mate within the first 10
moves
uh just to show
let's see how many people have fallen
into this on the chess
yeah if uh if Pawn takes Bishop 36 000
plus people have played this
the Knight T3 check means
so sad to the 277 people who played
Knight takes F3 not checkmate
and then this move is also possible it's
the same idea
very often they transpose
and then okay throughout the game
I mean
when we traded Rooks
it's only black who can win because this
Pawn is already a bit too far Advanced
on the light Square
and
and yeah I had like a slight Edge
I thought at some point maybe white
would play this and just try and like
hunker down
I would have still tried to like Walk
The King and make progress
although I guess yeah E4 walks into King
D4
and that was very gradual
oh Bishop E4 best move
yeah I wasn't sure about these King Pawn
endings takes takes takes takes
am I supposed to take with King
you need to
I win the pawn race
okay that's a cool graph white was
slightly better out of the opening
uh but gradually
at some moment it just kind of fell
apart
okay back to tournament
so I'll try and play even more
aggressively in the next game
um it was a draw with perfect play
ooh all right let's play assuming Queen
takes D5
okay not Queen takes D5
I think the most energetic move is
Bishop E5 check
I'll go into some Theory
there is a line like Bishop D7 Bishop
here
oh C6
so it's it's black who's gameting oh
that's funny
I guess we're we're both trying to play
aggressively
only one can prevail
are we gonna see this move
attacking the bishop and both Pawns
all right let's move the bishop back
I think Knight takes E6 should have been
played
oh I'm drinking um it's a new drink I've
been making this more often in the last
week
it's a iced
oat milk latte
with one of these coconut coffee pods
I have one of these like simple
Nespresso machines
um it's nice
weather's getting warmer so
gravitating towards cold colder drinks
okay I could take on a six
I think I will just to misplace a knight
I said Nespresso
which is capable of making espresso
drinks
I will be honest like the previous game
and this game have both been super solid
uh more than super aggressive
but I'm trying to develop my pieces and
then be aggressive later
all right let's play this move
this is kind of disguised as a defensive
move
but it has a threat of winning the night
one issue of the knights being
undefended on Asics
this is a very common like puzzle puzzle
Rush tactic
there's a lot of puzzle Rush positions
where
there's usually a bishop on E6 and you
you take it with your bishop and then
Queen A4 check
it's Paradox solid
oh yeah I muted TTS towards the end of
that last game
I had to stay focused let's replay this
TTS
played my first two tournaments OTB did
well and got a win over some decently
rated guys it's really nice to hear
yeah sometimes your your first OTB
tournaments can be nerve-wracking
but uh
there's a lot of fulfillment that can
come from playing playing over the board
chess
um doing well in over the board chess
too
thanks for sobbing a tier 3 for 27
months
all right
um the solid move would be castling
but the more aggressive move is 95.
trying to prevent black from casting
soon
and I'm essentially chasing the Queen
off this diagonal
so for example like
uh
yeah like Queen D4
I have Queen C6
how to do this there's also this move
between C6 I think is just winning on
the spot
hitting the king and Rook
if King E7
that Defender Rook
but then I really want to get Knight C6
with a fork
Central triple Fork
I'm thinking King E7 Queen B7
and then if Knight G7 I get the fork
if King f8 I checkmates
if King E8 I take on F7
King d8 and then I get the fork
I think every line I'm like either
mating or winning the black queen
of course Queen D7 I take the queen
the only thing I didn't calculate is
King D6
which probably locks into the F7
okay no mercy
yeah this is one of these um like
snowball effects
or downward spirals or in Black made
some
early inaccuracies of like allowing
the weaknesses on the queen side and
then had to be very careful here
the better move was probably Knight C7
um like get the Knight towards the
center
and of course before
like the main line in this position I
think there's two main lines either
Bishop D7 or Knight D7
okay all berserk
E3
okay how do I be aggressive against E3
start with um following opening
principles
maybe we'll have a reverse French
oh Queen H5
it's funny someone in shot was asking me
to play like the Wayward Queen attack
so opponent wants to Checkmate knee
probably
I'm not gonna allow it
although
if I play this there's this move
it's actually kind of weird
wow
the D5 Bishop B5 actually an interesting
like opening Nuance have the pawn on E3
because it's a weird configuration where
it's not so easy to defend
E5
or maybe it is maybe I'm just like
overthinking things let's play D5
gotta move quickly too
so I I blocked the bishop I attack the
bishop
assuming the bishop moves I'll just play
Bishop D6
nice Center
Knight F6 should come with Tempo against
the queen
or not
all right and I won't waste any time in
uh making threats
attacking the g-pawn I'm basically
trying to provoke some undesirable move
G3 or King F1
and now this move
yes using the initiative
um let's play Queen H5
as not so clear how light defends a
night now
the battery
is pretty strong
yeah I don't even need to play E4
it's a double attack and skewer
okay
that was a pleasant
the white King was the only developed
piece for white in the final position
okay well hopefully that's offers some
lesson of why you should not develop the
queen so early I was curious though like
after D5
let's say Knight F3 here
oh it's already minus two
I have three just not F6
okay
so trying to move up
top a thousand
okay I'll play E4 again
so we have that one scandi game
couple games ago
let's play a Grand Prix attack
it's one of the more aggressive options
for
um
all right I'll play G3
thank you Todd Maul gifting five
really appreciate that
so yeah this is more of a closed
Sicilian but there's a lot of potential
energy for whites
that's kind of this basic setup that
you can play against pretty much
whatever black does
and then the later middle game plans
involve okay of course casting
and then the gradual Pawn storm
sometimes E5 sometimes like H3 G4 and
maneuver the knights
the E5 first
and Queenie one
I'm trying to discourage F6
I was looking at some lines like F6 and
then F5
there's also G4 ideas
we'll play G4
Knight B4 so attacking the C Pawn
play Queen F2
and A3 would be logical
don't know if A3 is necessary though
because it just chases a knight back to
a square
or probably should be
although maybe Vlog wants to play this
94.95
I can already play F5 here
I kind of like
and it's going with the theme of playing
Super aggressively
not wasting any time
E3 maybe was a bit too slow
and now I free open the diagonal for the
bishop
so the bishop can come into F4 which is
my swear
or maybe I do as a queen G3 and Bishop
H6
but let's start with Bishop F4
the only thing I have to
look out for is F6
calculating uh Bishop for F6 and then
Queen G3
aches takes Bishop D6
hmm
I have rookie won as well
I have another idea I have A3 here
maybe now's the time because Knight C6 I
take on D5
the A3 runs into D4
it does get a little bit murky
A3 D4 take take
I'm more inclined to start with Bishop
F4
d494
okay
A3 was close to working I couldn't
figure out this line though
it really can't go wrong with developing
the bishop like this
aligning with the queen
F6 is a very risky move for black to
play
I'm actually not sure what to expect
here
in C8
all right so now I have this move
I mean it's similar lines though
let's do it
wow I think D4 had to be played
because now Knight takes D5 and
I win a pawn and okay there's
a lot of issues for black
and black can't really get away with
taking on E5 because E7 hangs
out Queen G3
yeah this game it's been more controlled
aggression like I played aggressively
but there's no need to sacrifice
anything
just gradually like migrating pieces
towards the king's side towards the
center
okay there's F6 threatening mate
I think I'll take first
and just open the bishop
and then this
the queen G5
getting closer
oh there's some funny lines
oh my knight
my beautiful night I blocked the Bishop
from defending the Knight
oh no
my queen
I keep losing things
someone call an ambulance
not for me
okay
it was a pleasant finish
Knight and queen sack
yeah Knight f8 would have maybe got
black defended for
a little bit longer
actually not that fate how do I break
through
in the positions really really nice for
white
Maybe 97.
9 f8 weights so after Rook F3 Knight
fades
yeah 97.
idea of being after it takes takes
I have Bishop coming in also upon just
attacking the knights
that was a fun position
[Music]
oh we need an ambulance emoji
or an ambulance emote
actually pretty good idea
oh F5 was apparently not the best move
but I think it cos black a lot of
problems
as she given what happened in the game
yeah D4 D4 is still difficult for buck
there's some F6 idea
yeah Roga 3 was technically dubious
but still completely winning
okay
all right that was a fun game
top 700.
I'm
I'm like 30 or 40 points away from my
rapid Peak
all right I'll play E4 again
hello Mr Rosen and chat hello
what's a play here
let's play ponziani it's aggressive
not quite a Gambit
but uh
yeah especially this line is
um is very tricky
even for stronger players
Bishop D7
now black is actually the one one who's
gameting
because white wins a pawn
black doesn't immediately win it back
yeah so the sell-up probably involves D3
and
develop the queen side pieces it is a
one drawback in panziani like sometimes
you'll get to positions like this where
C3 actually
prevents white from Quick development on
the queen side
and I don't necessarily want to play D4
but it is nice being up upon here
and kind of like Queen E2
Queen E2 or queen E3
Queen E2 probably
because later on the bishop still wants
to get in the game
yeah there was a point in time I was
studying this line from the black side
this E4 idea and then there's some
compensation
okay so I have D4 right away
which I do kind of like and there's also
D3
not sure about D3 castling because if I
take take I can't take the Knight
because rookie ate
but with D4 I take advantage of the
facts on poisson is not legal because of
the PIN
and now I have this move
trying to be active
and the darksword bishop does help
defend
potentially defend the pawn on D5
I I paralyzed one of the attackers
and the pawn on e4 is probably a bigger
weakness
I'm very tempted to play G4 here
because G4 Bishop G4 Bishop F6
if I win a piece takes takes
takes maybe I don't
there's F3
F3 actually looks quite nice
I don't see what black does in response
yeah it's nice like the last several
moves I've just gotten my pieces to
their ideal squares
and it's such a setup where D5 is
defended and E4 is attacked
and if takes I'm happy to trade queens
and simplify a little bit
Pawnee 3 just runs into Queen takes
I'm not sure what black does
castling I take here and then
yeah then they have three Center Pawns
this is not chocolate milk
this used to be an ice latte but then
the ice melted
now I guess it's just a room temperature
latte
or just a nice latte
okay
um yeah I'll take
away locks Crossing rights I'll take
with knights
so still up a pawn
and it's still not clear how black wins
back upon H6 was probably a good
practical move though
because if I play this G5
at least I have to make some decision if
I play this
what does block take with though
because both moves look undesirable
let's take
and castle
aligning with a Bok King
some threat of my H4 to win the bishop
G6 G4
I think I still play Knight H4 here
because then black can't really prevent
Knight takes Bishop
and then the pawn is gonna have to take
and then Bishop D3
it looks like I'm winning another Pawn
at least
not to mention G4 is still an idea
although G4 there's King G5
and then
gets a little bit weird
wow so box allowing G4
I guess now there's some idea like if
takes takes Bishop D3 there's Rook D5
I mean G4
there's a calculation King G5
I take with knights
GF Rook takes that five
King G4 Rook F1
and I'm threatening made in two with
Rook F4 King H3 Bishop F1 checkmate
and there's Rook g8s
Rook F4 King H3 King H1
I don't think block is stopping Rook uh
Bishop F1
let's go for this
and there's also a line uh King G5 takes
takes takes and then King G6
but then I'll be up two Pawns
okay so we're we're getting into this
and yeah I'm threatening made into
Roku one F4 and then
what's Ben Feingold saying
always play Bishop F1 checkmates
and Bishop one is usually a defensive
move
oh this is exactly what I was
calculating
so Rook F4
it's very important I have a Pawn on D4
if I had no Pawn on D4 if Rook G1 would
be checkmates
yeah not only is Bishop F1 and may
threat also Rook H5 is a main threat
we got opposition
the funny position
and the block King took a walk
and it entered the wrong neighborhood
okay that was a cool game
in my opponent played like this
interesting Gambit which has probably
been played
like a decent amount of times before
played over 100 times in the Master's
database
an engine
says is equal so it's playable for both
sides
that's very imbalanced
Queenie two
yeah I think this is yeah this is
definitely the first mistake
because it just lost time and time is
very valuable here
this is black who has a temporary lead
in development
did you consider 13 Bishop B5
see
very briefly it's one of these moves
that I think maybe was on my radar but
it just didn't make sense for
the overall plan for widen the position
even if it like maybe disturbs box play
oh it is one of the best moves
just once I saw F3 that's the type of
thing that seemed to make the most sense
I actually didn't realize like how bad
it is for back
like White's only of a pawn but the
engine says white stuff like six Pawns
hey
this is like pretty much a perfect game
I mean the play flowed really really
nicely
95 Rook F5
and this yeah this was forced made
apparently
okay
that was fun
top 500
XI Sparks won a game the other day
without losing a single Pawn or piece
wow
yeah that is pretty rare
it's reminding me of the game
the game that made Hans Neiman a grand
master
was a game it was 20 22 moves
and not a single piece was captured in
that game
he just won with with no captures
I do have a video somewhere on my
YouTube channel sharing that game
okay do I go for a Stafford
definitely fits the theme of super
aggressive chess
um
okay I'll play Bishop C5
still offering a sovereign
okay
so we we have a transposed staffer
Gambit
was not the typical move order
so there's two moves here there's Queen
D4 and there's H5 I think I'll play
Queen D4
I probably played H5 more often
sometimes they transpose into each other
I think this is paying off because
Knight F2
white maybe you just missed Knight F2
not only
do I win a pawn
but I'm hitting the queen I'm
threatening made in three I'm
threatening the smothered and oh no my
queen Jack needs and there's Brooke F2
we have two King H1 I'm with the bishop
so I'll be up a rook
okay
a 10 move Stafford Gambit win
yeah I think my opponent was just um
maybe saw that H2 was a Target saw this
idea
but didn't realize F2 was actually
attacked three times
doesn't happen too often in Rapid chests
huh win so quickly with a Saturn
yeah the best move is Bishop takes G4
and light's a bit better here
and then Bishop F4
what's the best line for black
ah G5 Bishop G3 Bishop D6 looks
interesting
still playable
okay
back to tournament
and gained a little bit of raid in this
tournament
yeah Magnus Carlsen as far as I know has
not played the Stafford online
but he did play the staffer Gambit once
in a park game it was a streets of
Madrid
like a chess Park during the candidates
and there's some video of him
playing soccer habits
made me so happy
okay Carol Khan
I'll play the two knights aggressive
option
Knight D7 okay this is a line
so developing quickly
Pawn E6
play this
I'm thinking it makes sense to avoid the
nitrate
because if takes takes then inbox has
already a little bit less space
and the Knights overlap
so I think the G3 is very logical here
this is not a main line
as far as I know
I think we need to
yeah usually
um
in this position I have success played
first
and then there's some different Theory
B5
I do have a choice here between Bishop
D3 and
E3
I'll play Bishop D3
aiming towards the king side
I wanna I do want to attack
I also want to be controlled with my
attack
I think I'll start with
before
Vlog wants to play C5
I guess A4 makes sense
one way to prevent C5
now I'm trying to take take and then
take with the pin on the a file
so expecting this move
yeah trying to figure out the plan still
like 95 comes to mind
I think 95 looks nice
thank you XI Sparks gifting to Black
Lotus
appreciate that
oh also gifting to JM Erickson
was my my previous opponents
at the interesting ponziani game
oh jam Erickson wrote a nice message in
chat
yeah the Gambit that we had was
interesting but it does require some uh
I think some deeper preparation
okay this Pawn is under attack
and Bishop E3 I think makes a lot of
sense
aligning with the queen
there's ideas of Pawn D5
unleashing the bishop
and light now can't be taken because
takes and then I hit the queen in the
night
wow
okay this move
gives me options so D5 is a move
I don't think I'll play D5 though like
Queen C7
I'm more inclined to just take on A4
and then just see what black does
there's cases later where the Rook
swings all the way over
and then get some crazy attack
potential Bishop H7 sacrifices
okay
is it gonna happen
if I take
wait a minute
I think I want to take on D7 first
but then I have to worry about this move
do you have D5 or no no I
mean C6 I have this move
and then this move hey it's Pam happy 33
months
refreshing is a great way to solve solve
all the problems
okay so Knight takes takes
and if I take here
100 sure
I think I'll start with this move though
it makes a knight move away from the
King side
okay black is considering this move
but as a pretty simple calculation of
takes takes Bishop E4
and now if I take
green C6
yeah this Rook is more of a Target than
anything else
I play Bishop H7 King H7
what about D5
I don't know what to do
I could defend the Rook
like B3
B3 might be the way to go
a defensive b-pawn too
it's not like the aggressive move I want
to play but
I think it's
it's the easiest move to understand
and now if Queen C6 I can safely Play
Bishop E4
okay just found a lot of time there
another six can I play this move now
cool tactic though fake
and then that H5
the idea is if takes
I simply take back and then hit the pawn
and Bishop
and now the fourth rank is completely
clear for The Rook
not sure what black is going to do next
Bishop E7 I just take the queen so The
Bishop's pinned
there is Bishop takes E3
but then maybe even I take take
and then take take Rook H4
almost working
yeah we both have dreams of attacking on
the king side
and this bishop is still menacing but
I think I I just have more potential
attackers
Knight Rook Bishop queen other Bishop
Okay so
yeah it definitely makes sense to throw
in this move
and now do I go for the sack
I think I do
wait
there's a few lines
um I was mainly calculating King H7
after which I play Rook H4 Bishop H6 and
then Queen H5
and there's just no defending the bishop
so after it takes Rook H4 there's King
G7
but then I take and then I'm threatening
Queen G4 which is very hard to stop
if at five I have Queen H5 Rook h8
and then Queen G5 King f8 takes and
uh that's actually mating
yeah the queen and Bishop are a bit
sidelined like they're not in great
shape to
defend the king side
I did mention this much earlier like
when my Rook came to A4 I was mentioning
ideas of exacting and swinging over
it's finally happening
and black has three legal moves
start with this
so yeah when the king moves to the G
file I don't immediately have mates
because Bishop G5
Queen G4 be a series mistake but yeah
wherever the king moves I think I just
take the bishop
and then Queen G4 is
nearly Unstoppable
like the only move to stop it is F5 and
then Queen H5
oh there is a line though wait
maybe it's not over
and I missed
uh this is not over
I overlooked A variation
this is still very interesting
in here
oh that move I forgot about two
oh no
this is completely losing
ah that defends G5
ah
oh no
yeah this is really bad
I've worked G4
there's only hope
wait what Chuck
what just happened
I was just completely losing but now I'm
mating next move
I was not an intentional oh no like that
was an actual oh no I missed Queen E3
by black fellow fur
and final trick
wow oh yeah there's one legal move and
then checkmates
got very very fortunate there
I can't play my point for like not
moving immediately
what to do
thank you Andy
oh man
yeah King F6 was a
I think just still winning for Bach
because my queen is essentially trapped
so it is winning for white but Rook H4
was a blunder
I had to take first
so keeping the pawn defended
and then the ideas of this or this
yeah the difference is the King's on
each seven here
so there's no time to set up like this
F5 and King Escape
and there's no time for Queen E3 either
ah but Rook G8 yeah maybe it's still
tricky Rook G8
is winning though after this this this
this this
ah because F6 ends up falling
but some long line of like hunting down
the king
there's a D5 E4 man
and I checked D5 instead of B3
so in this position
[Music]
um
this came to mind
but then Bishop D5
I wanted to do things of attacking but
the problem is I don't think anything
works concretely
because if I take take here here I want
to play Rook H4 but the bishop covers H4
and if I attack H5 right away if there's
not F6
I would be down the pawn here
man look at this graph
I was winning and then losing and then
very losing and then winning
oh
yeah so B3 I think was like the best
yep top move and also like
it was one of these like simple to play
moves it didn't really require much
calculation
okay back to tournaments
thank you Jim Jam James is helping me
Drift Off to Sleep thanks Eric
oh my pleasure
not sure if it'll be easy to sleep after
that last game
some roller coaster finish
I'm used to those comments though a lot
of people watch my content to relax
okay playing this person
I'll wizard back
so I play The Budapest earlier let's
play D5
I'll still play in an aggressive salad
some aggressive approach
I'll play Pawn C5
I do take it as a compliment
it's nice to know that people find find
this relaxing
all right so playing my go-to setup
against London
Bishop D3
this is not the most common move order
like usually white has a knight
developed
before both Bishops developed
but I guess it's playable
if I play this and takes
actually thinking of playing Queen A5
here
like keeping Queens on the board
and now threatening Pawn C4
and if I take
doesn't really accomplish much
on C4 actually accomplishes something
because now I'm basically forcing Bishop
C6 and after he takes
get the bishop pair and the B file
oh there is that move though
let's take
I play this
I want to get both the whites Bishops
like we might end up seeing both Bishops
trade for both my Knights
hmm Bishop D1
is an option
I'll play this though
and then Knight F5
Bishop H5 is met with King d8
some weird Maneuvers here
yeah this is a way more strategic game
I'm still trying to play energetically
gained a bit of space
Bishop C7
let's attack the bishop
I think I'm forcing it to move back
and now upon H5
threatening to trough the bishop
F3 hangs E3
and any each pawn move I take and then
light structure is not
so pretty looking
okay it's still a question like what my
plan is
because the knight's gonna try and
establish a post
maybe I just play E5
and then prepare this and this
a very interesting Bond structure here
let's play this
um
right this is the only
fully open file
I am allowing Bishop G6 which
be close to winning a pawn
if I take
can't use too much time
to move back
yeah there's a funny line like Bishop G6
I play this I allow
a pawn to be taken
and then King D6
and now the bishop is stuck as I defend
G4
and I'm ready to play Rook off five
oh but Rook F5 I lose a pawn
I didn't think this through
I play this there's Bishop F7
hmm
visit D7
Eventing Knight P5
others
it's getting spicy
and E3 is a big Target now
you see E4
I probably still hop into E3
but there's also this move to calculate
there's also that move
so take they gave me just trade
um
I think black is still for choice and we
are trading a lot though
the night's completely out of play
you might see Knight C2
and that's probably to do this
this I play this
back in The Rook
okay the aggression begins
and take
I have this move
may have had that move
did this move first
and why it's completely stuck be funny
if we see Knight C1 Rook D2 checkmates
a funny mating idea
I think it's force made now Knight E3
King has to move and then I move here
here and then checkmate
or if King D1 this is checkmates
nothing can block the bishop
okay
that was fun
it was a nice little um
mating that with a
using the night rook and Bishop
yeah very weird sequence of like opening
moves
even starting with this move order
curious what I'm supposed to do here
engine like C4 immediately
wasn't sure about this line takes takes
and then this
I guess B5 B4 is still
pretty much coming
okay playing loaffa in South Africa
okay I'm not gonna have a Stafford
I'll play play Knight C6
okay what's an aggressive line I can
play
um
F5
I'm allowing takes takes Queen H5
but I mean it looks fun this looks fun
too
oh D5
and then Bishop D6
oh 84
okay though the opening is paying off
I was a bit hesitant
like I'm trying to play Super
aggressively but not like super
dubiously
can be a
fine line to balance
the H6
those Knight is getting kicked around
yeah welcome to all the new people here
um apologies it's sometimes hard to
like interact with everyone as I'm
playing these games
uh trying to make things instructive
uh Bishop D6 or Bishop C5
undermined
I mean there's also Bishop takes H6
kind of spoiled for Choice here
I like the prospect of
taking on each three Knight D4
and this is kind of playing in the style
to try and win
as quickly as possible
but I think it's Justified
I just want to play Knight F3 and then
main on H2
how does white stop it now there's only
a move to prolong the game
I'm curious if this opening has a name
like a five against the Vienna
okay
those wins more material
ip5 I have this move
or no I have this move
upon defended
okay where's my mate
let's play this first and
I'll just keep throwing punches
even if they're not directed towards the
king
ooh
attacking and covering E1
wow
when game goes on
now threatening to trap the bishop
also defending the pawn
actually C5 is very multi-purpose I
defend I threaten this and I threaten
this
and the Knight is like weirdly maybe not
fully trapped
but it keeps getting kicked around
now I trap the bishop
no more checks
so now I have a choice which piece to
take
[Music]
um
take this
okay so I'm threatening the knights
threatening both Pawns
and most importantly threatening made in
one
there's a few checks that eventually run
out
I see the comment from gohar no no
uh
saw a video on YouTube on how to play
the London
oh nice to hear
I haven't actually played the London
opening this this stream
I've been playing more aggressive
options
like whatever I just did in this game
Pawn F5
thank you Yuri schleifman first time
Prime
oh so this is not even a losing move
yeah it looks like white could go for
this but then it's actually an
interesting Gambit
a white winds upon but then Black's
actually doing quite well here
wait did I miss meet
Queen G5 on move 18.
queen queen G5 is met with Bishop takes
G5
I mean maybe there were other ways to
win more efficiently
and so far I'm um
I'm saying clean at least result wise
or is that one game I should have lost
um
that Karo Khan game
against this person I could play Joe
Baba London
yeah maybe if I'm white next game
can be like very aggressive
the player but also the opening
all right so D4 almost every game has
been E4 today and Knight C3 so this is
Joe Bava London
uh box offering to transpose into
Carroll Khan
but
yeah no thanks
but now E4 actually makes some sense
because black wants to play Bishop D6
I'll play E4
H6 this is opening
F3
okay so just following opening
principles
usually in Joe Bravo London the pawn
goes to E3 but
I I jumped on the chance to play E4
and now there is pressure against the
epon because Knight's pinned
um I could play this move
but this runs into this
okay I have an idea
the sacrifice upon
if Knight E4 I just Castle
I sack upon on C3
there's a chance black won't even play
94 though
yeah this is not the typical jobava
London like you always have to react to
what the
current position presents
it resembles more of a French now
bad Bishop on C8
maybe black will go for C5 at some point
but it really depends on like how the
next few moves
unfold
Knight D7 okay
so this doesn't really cause me any
issue
I'm happy to Castle
wow
okay so now I would love to attack on
the king side
what's the best way to do it
F5 might be coming
I'm actually thinking about playing C4
the idea is to open
way for this C2 Pawn
because eventually I want to create the
battery
we do see F5 I'll take
yeah still at the stage of like trying
to optimize the pieces
like the minor pieces are happy
the major pieces want to enter the game
this is a long-term weakness
if Knight D7 lose a pawn or allow this
okay now it looks like I'm winning
material like I have Bishop D6 and Rook
F7 Bishop G6
yeah just a lot of holes in box position
I don't have to take the Rook actually
Knight E5 is I think just devastating
for back
is I'm going to take the next move
potentially forking the queen and king
okay
team move win
with what star does the jobava London
but like very quickly turned into kind
of a dubious French Sherlock
these moves don't don't always combine
that well
I think maybe block was in the mindset
of trying to play a semi-soft
but semi-slav it's more justifying it's
Queen's Gambit
against Joe Bava London these moves
don't really serve much of a purpose
so top hundred
yeah very far away from
getting the shield
and yeah my goal with this tournament is
not to like win it or finish highly it's
really just to have some instructive and
fun games
I'll play another job in London
oh
okay let's play E4
I'm the one who gambits
Queen E7 what is this
[Music]
you just take admission D3
I think black is still trying to play in
the style of an England
I want to play aggressively though
let's play this
takes all take with Queen
ooh all right let's take
Knight of three
there's also F4
but 903 just offers quicker development
I'm losing a lot of time moving the
queen early
Bishop C4
okay rookie one is a move
I do want to accomplish this E5 break
I'll start with rookie one
actually
Bishop F4 is developing with tempo
a d-pawn is attacked
and this is probably a good example of
what not to do in the opening
a black not developing any minor pieces
let's move the queen a few too many
times
but it still takes work to actually
punish
like I want to play this move but then
D5
maybe Queen D2 first
preparing Rook D1 may be preparing E5
Rook D1 looks nice
now I could take the pawn for free
but
I don't think there's any reason to like
the pawn is just hanging
I'm giving myself the option
oh maybe I should have taken the pawn
oops
um
yeah that move is actually like very
annoying
ah what have I done
take
this would be three first
box actually completing development
and White's probably still for choice
I should have taken the d-pawn when I
had the chance
I get f8s
okay so if I
gotta do this
we need three
let's move first preparing F4
or
Knight G4 there is this move threatening
May and the Knight
okay finally winning material
and King H1 is useful just getting off
the diagonal
and we'll begin the migration to the
king's side
try and get some attack
mainly ideas of F6
oh
okay so Knights pinned and attacked
three times now
I'm also hitting the bishop and this
Pawn is overworked on G7
I took some patience
still making progress
I think this game is about to end with a
rook lift
or a free Queen
and a free rook
and then a rook lift
uh what's the quickest win
I'll lift another Rook
okay
yeah I should have taken the pawn
I didn't want to trade Queen so early
but Knight E5 is actually like a nice
black hating move the neutralizes this
diagonal offers some trades
well I could have maybe played Bishop G4
here okay we'll do at least one more
66 plays
here we go
playing Gabriel
hey it's Thomas what's up Thomas
thanks for the raid
hope you had a good stream
if you're just joining I'm playing Super
aggressive rapid chess
I'll offer a Stafford if white wants it
oh let's play this um
there's an opening I played earlier
Bishop C4 F5
reverse Kings gamut
have you created any openings
you should watch my most recent YouTube
video
I was getting chat GPT to create some
new openings
we do have the new vid command
it was actually a fun stream I might uh
I might do something like that again
you just
have basically have twitch chat
need prompts to chat GPT
and then come up with
just a lot of cool stuff
okay this is maybe a little bit
questionable for black because I can't
actually Castle
[Music]
thing is pinned
I can't play D5
I guess I play this move
I went back the pawn
okay
um wait a minute
big take
I really want a sack of a queen but
and we lose a queen not lead so much
let's take here first
Queen H5 I have Bishop G6 thankfully
where is this movie though
then D5
yeah this should be okay for luck
and white was briefly threatening Bishop
G7
but now that's no longer a concern
I think I'll play Rook G8
yeah again this opening is paying off
maybe I'll have to explore this this
opening further like F5
it's something I I have played before
kind of as a joke
but if the engine says it's not so bad
and so many people do play the Vienna
these days
it's as if I strike white with their own
Gambit
thank you sub-optimal
all right White's applying a bit of
pressure
there's this move
I'm gonna see Queen G3
I wrote G6
so I'm basically unpinning the bishop
because now the rook's defended
there's a funny move Bishop D1
probably there's no reason to play
there's Pawn D4
actually kind of like this move
takes takes the queen activates
also preparing castling
I still really want to play there's a D1
wait this is probably just simpler
although
[Music]
um
let's start with this
the attacking the queen
now I can take
and take on G2
Castle
[Music]
taking on G2
then Queen H5 let's Castle
[Music]
okay so now I have Queen B4 check
but my Rooks attacked
I'll take on G2 first
we might see Queen side Gosling
or not
yeah it looks like I'm winning the
bishop and then there's King F1
looking at Queen D2
it's very close to mating
threatening made in one there's Queen H4
which
maybe the only move that defends
I have this move
but am I threatening anything
oh there's a funny mate it's made in
three
Rook G1
Rogue takes G1 Bishop takes H3
no mercy
was there 14 Bishop D1
yeah I spent some time on it
it's playable
I just didn't want to like complicate
things
when it wasn't necessary
I win C2 will lose H7 when G2 maybe
you'll have some checks
I figured
what I did was a simpler line
so
um I I guess I'll do one more
almost top 50.
okay
what have I done so far
we haven't really had a true Joe Battle
London
or even like a true London
oh sorry if I muffled a sound I'll try
and be careful
okay let's play Knight C3
and we'll have another Joe Bava London
what button do push so you can analyze
like that
uh it's analysis board it's usually when
you finish a game
there's no button during the game
but after the game is Just analysis
and that's a nice feature
okay
here we go
C5 let's play E4
this is the line that I like to play as
black
these lines sometimes lead to like an
early Queen trade
uh yeah we'll take
in this move
Bishop D7 is the main move
oh The Queen Is Now attacked
and take
we are entering some
kind of theoretical line
um
although this
I thought the main move is Bishop take
C6
and when a pawn here it takes takes
takes
we made five of I move back Knight takes
E6
in D2
yeah I mean a very basic level I had
three attackers only two Defenders
always have to watch out for tricks
though
like Queen A5 is one of the main
resources
which does not seem to work
sc5
C5 is interesting because if I take
there's a pawn E5
but I don't have to take the pawn
move back to D2
and this Pawn is
being very strong
thank you QE DHS another first time
Prime sub
do appreciate that
yeah this opening is going very well
I went upon and
I have a lot of like other types of
advantages more Center more development
or space
you also to
wait let me let me figure out my next
move first
we'll just develop
due to wayfaring Wayfarer
another first time crime
that seems like every stream there's new
people finding out that they can
subscribe for free
support the channel I do appreciate it
okay Pawn D6
the most aggressive move make the bishop
go back to where it came from
it's La Fong what's up lafong
nice timing
La Fong's raid prompted my opponent to
resign in combination with my d-pong
yeah if you're just joining
um
I just won an 11 moves with uh Joe Bava
London
yeah there's some other line here like
black should take with the bishop
defending
and then E5 Knight D7 E6 is actually a
really cool line
there's a game Wesley's so
or no
it was a game
I thought there was a Wesley game but
maybe not in the sign
oh this game
ah Wesley played A6
Wesley actually got into trouble in this
game
it was a cool idea
I was gonna wrap things up but gotta
play at least one more
welcome back Pammy J
yeah we've been having some fun Justice
stream
playing the rapid Shield Arena
at the very beginning of the stream I
ran a poll
asking if people want solid chests or
aggressive chess
aggressive chess barely won
so I've been playing every game
trying to play aggressively
and I've managed to win all the games so
far
there's at least one I was like
completely losing but
yeah some luck has been on my side
thank you Soki another first time Prime
opponent offline
they left the game they have 10 seconds
to move
oh no my opponents
oh
[Music]
okay free reading hey it's Joe brune
what's up Joe brune
now that's a Joe
if you're just joining
I wanted Zero moves
I got rated uh also by lafon about a
couple minutes ago
and when lafong raided I won in 11 moves
these reads are bringing Good Fortune
I'm still kind of far away
but
man I'm on a streak
if I keep playing until I lose
I don't want to like curse myself or
jinx myself
I've been having some like pretty quick
wins
whoa it's another raid chest nerd live
what's up chest nerd
that's like three raids in three minutes
I do appreciate it shout out to Chester
hope you had a good one
I was really thinking about wrapping
things up but
I think I'm due for at least a few more
games
again if you're just joining I'm playing
chess
um it's been rapid chess but this this
game is gonna be Blitz
I'm trying to play Super aggressively
every game
I guess here we'll have a reverse Joe
Battle London
Bishop F5
and night before this is a line
revoking Knight A3 essentially
yeah I was trying to be aggressive but
we're going into more solid territory
D4 is a very fine move
um well Castle
I think A5 is logical
and this is very typical
okay do I want to play A4 there's also
Bishop F6
there's F6
I'm leaning towards F6 it looks strange
but I didn't want to allow 95 and I want
to play some like Queen D7 eventually
oh wow
Knights may be coming to F5
I could play Pawn F5
which is a little bit sus
say this first
yeah this is this is pretty much a Blitz
game so
I do have to manage my time
um probably conceding the bishop hair
I get the chance I would like to play
Bishop f8 but I don't
at least I have happy nights
Rook is ready to come to d8
they're just ready to return to G6
I just missed a tactic ah
I had this move
or did I
I did
I still threatening it
maybe not
this is such a natural move I just
didn't consider anything else
uh what to do
in here first
that's still a nice position
in this move
or this move
I like the queen on E6
more centralized
I just missed another tactic
okay I should be considering the the
forcing moves the captures
in Knight G3 maybe I think G3 was just
I'm missing things as the scheme
let's play this
it's still a good position though
so F3 would be a sad move for this
bishop
a five perhaps
trying to clamp down
thank you hambo hey Eric hey huge fan
here from Manchester UK I appreciate
that
happy seven months
upon E3
and play bondage six
okay G5
lingering ideas
I'm okay with the trade
takes I take with this Pawn
and now the plan is King G7
Rook h8
we can begin being very aggressive
hopefully
I mean yeah if I got The Rook to h8
Bishop to F3 Queen to H3
might even sacrifice the queen
white is very limited on like defenses
okay
I'm thinking uh Rook D7 makes
idea that I defend the pawn in the event
to B5 and The Rook can just swing over
to H7
and the Knight
and he just returns back
Bishop F3
getting the dream position
[Music]
Queen H3 is a threat I think
the queen H1 also but Queen H3 is more
static
I still play Queen H3
I mean there's also made in three year
I'll sacrifice
The Rook
okay it's good I didn't pre-move Queen
G2
oh
okay that was a cool game
yeah I missed a few tactics
this may be a result of playing chess
for
over two hours now
uh the first tactic was Knight takes F2
which I think works although there is
another five
Liverpool UK haha how to do that for the
comrade from Manchester oh hey greetings
from Liverpool and shout out to all your
fans in the north of England I
appreciate that welcome back thing
Duster
okay nightlife 2 apparently was losing
because Nana five so that was a good
thing to miss
if I saw it I probably would have taken
some time like to calculate
and then later okay I miss Knight G3
which yeah
which is crushing because E2 is attacked
the pawn is overworked
okay back to tournament
24th Place
I mean I'm nowhere near first cheers to
all your great content I'm I'm getting
closer
thank you Robin Spector
okay I'm about 20 points away from my
rapid Peak
I peaked somewhere in the 2660s
it's only first place who gets the
shield
all right let's play E4
I had fun with Joe Bava London
the Turning okay those are back
returning to the king's pond
a two nights attack
I played this once earlier this stream
but we had a slightly different line
Bishop E2
Knight B1 they use staffordiana 12.
first time sub
hmm
okay
new type of position for me
I like the idea of C3
just
fourth black to make a decision
because E5 walks into Bishop C4
D5 could walk into some checks
there's this move Knight E5 Queen moves
D3
8 Bishop B5 why not
then D3
or do I take
taking actually makes some sense
Knight's pinned if the queen takes on I
I play D3 anyway
hmm
interesting position
I would like to set up for some attack
grumpy Bavarian
I wonder if ducks ever quack
the signal grumpiness
maybe it's a signal hunger
I appreciate the hype
do have a train of hype
okay what to do here
Knight D2 there's Queen H5
okay let's bring the Knight to C4
imagining like Castle takes on the
Knight C4
really nice post for the night maybe I
could have taken first
at night is so good here Revenge 95
defense B2
it can't be attacked by a black pawn
like maybe he wants to go for F5
I want to go for F4
also hitting E5
okay F4 loses a pawn
Play Bishop D2
The Rook wants to align with the queen
of 500 bits
really appreciate that
wow
and G3
G3 is usually a good move when there's a
knight on G6
restricts tonight but this also prepares
Pana for
I am opening up my own King
I'm trying to make progress with attack
ooh
didn't see that move coming
upon a five
I completely forgot about this move
thankfully I don't think it's that bad
for me
black doesn't go for it
how to do this
preparing to swing over keeping the
tension
I do have Knight D6
or ferta
eat my night though
more drawn to Bishop E5
might be the wrong decision
yeah the bishop I mean it's on a nice
post and it
like it's controlling a lot of dark
Spurs
but it can't touch anything on the light
squares
and that's where almost all my things
are
ready to play King H1
that's really closing down
uh let's play this move
now there's a simple plan of doubling
could win the pawn to
okay
putting the King on the light Square
root G1 coming soon
and yeah the nice thing about the Knight
it's like always covering B2
it was so hard for lock to do anything
on the queen side
oh but on the king side
wow
E3
play this first
getting spicy
is getting very spicy
if I was maybe not a good move
but maybe it was
wait a minute takes
I get away with this
I'm up the exchange now
King's kind of open
be really careful here
if only if we see G5 on Persona I lose
my queen
oh no my Rook
I think everything's under control
there's Queen you want Rook G1
brooktex Rockets made in a few
okay
I'm back
this
I just trapped the Queen the Queen's
just trapped
had no moves there
unexpected Queen trap
okay
I was uh that was a tense game
yeah when I play that five I completely
forgot about Queen
G3
but after King H1 I think it's okay for
bites
I had such a nice chest come win against
D4 using some of your Queen's Gambit
declined ideas I saw you play it really
helped because my opponent blundered a
knight forgetting the queen was on A5
put it in a study in case you're
interested oh it sounds like it
Cambridge Springs
yeah feel free to uh share a link
or whisper meal link
that's nice to hear
actually I haven't played the Cambridge
Springs yet
I think I played D5 like D4 D5 in one
game this tournament
well that one game was a London
okay playing macko
dessert back
let's play Joe Battle London
or let's play this
lava pures or a philodor
or a ponziani
panziani time
uh H3 oh no my Pawn
thank you Kirker first time Prime
okay
with a pawn here like take some takes
oh really
wait I mean you're
wow
I'm still winning a pawn at the end of
this
but Queenie two there's Queen E7
there's this move
and after all the trades like takes
takes takes takes
lights up a pawn
one's considering this move
which I don't think works because
Wing G2 Queen F3
[Music]
ah this is a person in fourth place
they're actually close to like catching
the leader
okay so we do see this line
but now lights off a piece okay 12 move
win the ponziani
yeah I guess the two Ponzi two ponziani
games I had this tournament
are both relatively quick
so top 20.
still a lot of points to make up
I've I've won the last three berserking
still on a streak
playing Sapphire
okay
I had one staffer Gambit at this
tournament this will not be a Stafford
uh let's play this line
this is probably the more or the most
like interesting line to play against
3d4
it's a temporary peace sacrifice but
after Bishop E4 there's D5
and a lot of players just are kind of
confused by this or not prepared for
this
uh the previous game was Joe Bava London
Pierce philodor and ponziani
yeah I guess move one it was an intended
job of London
okay so now six
is important
preparing E4
I played this line against Chicago
before
I think he takes takes forget what he
does after that though
okay
I'm inclined to take the Knight but I
can take the bishop
I think the bishop just looks better
wait what does this line takes takes
uh text takes
is no good for me because I lose a rook
but if takes I take with Bishops
if takes with Chuck
maybe I take with Queen
because then Queen D3 I don't mind
trading Queens
of course rookie one Bishop E7
windy three
hmm
but I guess the point is after it takes
Rook here here there's Queen E2
I'm in a small bind
what if I take your first we trade
Queens
rookie one
[Music]
I feel like that's the way to go
off for the queen chain I'll be up upon
there are lines with Knight G5 that I
have to play Bishop B6
this I was less concerned about because
now
I don't have to worry about having to
take with the King on d8
I guess there is takes takes Knight G5
but then Bishop E7
takes takes takes doesn't work for white
because I mate
and I think I'm up a clean Pawn here
not seeing much
I guess there's this move
and maybe that's the best approach for
whites
my D4 Queen D7
in White's taking time here
between E2
a little bit unexpected
I mean White's preparing this move next
so how to best do this bishop D6
this move looks really slow but
that's why I deal with this
I think I might just play H6
because my G5 was really the only
concern
maybe there's a bishop here
would break the file or break the
battery
man there's a chance I might end up
playing the rest of this tournament
I was gonna end like several games ago
when all the raids came in
what to do
still not sure though I just depend on
how this game goes
well I played this
Knight D4 takes takes
Bishop D6 and Knight D4 takes takes
takes takes two
I have to be careful there's also a
bishop B4
which is kind of a cool move
the provokes C3 and then I move back
and then there's no Knight C3
I think I'll play Bishop B4
sometimes you see this idea in other
openings
there's a line in the scotch where you
you play this and then move back
actually I'll probably go back to E5
okay so Knight C3 now I can take
emulator
white still has some initiative
yeah because Knight D4 is still coming
oh 95.
like D5
now I want to play this move
um
debating which Rook to move
they're probably more logical for the F
Rook
yeah because this Rook wants to come to
d8
Knight B6 for Knight F6 now
Knight B6 pressures upon
the king side lust defended
I'm playing that F6
now challenging the D file
not see that move coming I think it's
just a fancy trade though
like we trade everything I'll still be
up a pawn
I think I'm might actually be winning
the C Pawn in the very very end
depending what white blocks with yeah so
after Rook blocks
I can take
and then get in C5
and there's a simple maneuver which I
don't know if it can be stopped
although yeah White's King gets in kind
of quickly
it's still tricky
there's also Bishop C3
happening 98 King F2 Knight D6 King E3 I
take
E4 out of C6
yeah let's go for the sign
if ever the pawns attacked I pawn B6
it's a cool idea huh
hey White's gonna try and get the king
active but after this this this
it's as if I create a wall that the king
can't really pass
even though my team is completely out of
it
like all these works are controlled
light skiing it's like it's fully
optimized
I can't really optimize further
I've
probably not B5
playlist for now
I think I'll go for G5
ideas of this and this just so my
g-pawn's no longer a Target
still create this barrier
and almost all the squares around the
king are controlled
if the king moves back to D3 out of
Knight D6
let's take
A5
other raid Alexandra chess
appreciate the read
if you're just tweeting I have to say
focused
like it feels like I'm on the verge of
winning
takes a little bit more effort
of two Pawns
the idea is to go for V5 eventually
that wants to play
the pawn on each five
I think this is good enough
I do a lot of light to win a pawn
go for this
and there's Bishop A1
opposite of h8
uh
ready to win this Pawn
also preventing King G4 there's King G5
one plan is just to put a Pawn on C3 and
then
race down with a pawn
yeah welcome to all the new people here
you're just joining this is a rapid
Shield Arena
been streaming for almost three hours
now
and having a lot of fun games
this one no exception
this one is one of the longer ones I've
had in a while actually
H5 I think I have to throw in this
although maybe I just keep
doing my thing
so here here here
and the calculate
the tricky move
and this was a safe option
can't get too relaxed here still have to
be precise
the d4c3 or B3
E3 H5 B3
A4
so A4
H6 97
Bishop C5
E3
A4 should work
yeah the whole idea is I got the Knight
to G6 so after H7 Knight G6
it's pretty clear
and then this is a line that
um it was actually kind of tricky wait
miscalculated Bishop C5 B3
anyway
I have to fight D3
I miscalculated
it should still be winning though
I think
I have this move
although
if I take
[Music]
um
yeah this is winning now
e2b1
wasn't so simple though
I think white could have played the H7
and move sooner
oh man
okay that was close
plenty of time
yeah there is a move
um oh Bishop takes E7 yeah
and then
it's really not so clear I think I was
going to take on Nissan with a king
why is B2 stronger H7
C2 oh wow
oh King G7 is simpler though
yeah it's still winning
g7s
um
not sure if I would have played that
accurately though
oh what a game
33 Knight B6
he has a position where I have a lot of
options might be six is playable
um
maybe six probably A5
why not King E6 I didn't want my um my
Pawn to get fixed on each six
again everything's winning
it was a matter of technique
I technique probably could have been
improved
I play another I'm getting tired
but I'm on the streak
a long win streak 18 games
still top 20.
okay probably one more
Breeze of Dreams in the top ten
playing E4
okay I almost look back
we have a modern
there's a weird line like Knight C6 E5
not happening here though
I'm definitely feeling the chest fatigue
I think I have to take Bishop G5
Rook team one
the queen E7 runs into this
not sure if I got much from the sign
Play Bishop H4 maintaining the PIN
wait I didn't berserk
I'm just realizing I thought I berserked
I swear I clicked the button
how did that happen
I misperserked
I'm so confused
I swear I I heard this sound but maybe
it was like the timing was off
I think I've seen this happen before
I really thought I berserked
the H4
yes I have time on this game
okay Knight H2
existing position F3
the file is now guaranteed to open
I'll probably still castle like even
though I've played F3 and H4 the King
still finds safety
um
okay trying to soften the queen side a
bit
A5 will leave the Knight undefended
now I Castle
hmm
the Box still goes for casting Queen
sign
very bold decision
I like Queen E3
simply attacking the knights a knight
just only has one saved Square on A8
then the queen can Venture in
you can see seven aligns with the bishop
yeah King C7 I probably play Queen G5
we do see
I'll play Queen A7
this Knight wants to be on B6 I can't
even draw the arrow
settings reset
all right let's take hitting the pawn
update my preferences
okay if I take with a rook I got
skewered
then Rook d8
I'll take with Knight
now I can draw this Arrow
still have to be careful though let's
play this move
running a seven
actually the the Knight is finding the
most
efficient path to B6
all right on each two
starting on G1 actually
well the only thing if I get to B6 it's
not meat
maybe my queen will return to A7
what was the setting for the arrow
change
it's in preferences and then game
Behavior
and then uh snap arrows
okay I'll take on F7
it is getting spicy
there's this move
that the bishop would be hanging
I'm looking at Queen D6 Rook takes G7
Knight takes Rook Knight C4 Queen D4
Bishop F oh Bishop F2 there's Queen F2
though
something along those lines
I see the comment doesn't he have a fork
at E3
I did temporarily get Forks
but uh this is a counter-attack
and now it's about to get very messy
I mean
I don't think I'm risking much
and then Knight C4
so I do allow the check and then King H2
and we get a situation where my queen
Knight Rook Bishop they're all kind of
set up nicely to
an attack
Castle King
there's some really beautiful lines here
debating which ones to choose I think
I'll take your
first
I left one and then King
goes back
wait a minute I take here there's Knight
C4
maybe I'll play this first
and then I'll take
I'm threatening the queen I'm also
threatening Maiden one there's a funny
mate threads
green A8
there's Knights pins are the king
is pretty much other checks
okay
it was a cool finish
green ah checkmates
okay I'm gonna wrap things up I'm kind
of tired
but have a lot of fun games
um
overall I played
19 games
100 win rate
I gained a little bit of reading
approaching top 50 on each ass
let's see this leaderboard
I'll probably put the whole tournament
on you on YouTube
um a lot of fun games I think a lot of
instructor value too